thank you
welcome to Worlds of speculative fiction
session 72. we are going back to an
author who we looked at before with a
Trilogy of his Works J.G Ballard and now
we're looking at an earlier and more
thematically connected Trilogy of some
of his very earliest novels the World
Series we could call them Each of which
represents a way in which the universe
as we know it the world that we live in
starts to go wrong for human beings
although not necessarily for everything
else so we're going to be talking about
the drowned World which came out in 1962
a book that now is translated as the
drought but originally was called The
Burning World it might have been changed
in part because there's another in
important novel out there called The
Burning world that came out in 64. and
then this very interesting the crystal
world that came out in 66 and each of
these represents as I mentioned a way in
which things go awry in an ecological
global scale and in some respect they
can be a little bit prescient scarily
prescient for ways that we'll we'll
discuss later now we're going to be
talking about World building and the
depiction of the world that we actually
live in and we'll look at some things
that Ballard himself had to say about
these particular
novels the sequence the individual books
we'll look at what goes on in them and
some really important philosophical
themes now if this is your first time to
Worlds of speculative fiction let me
welcome you but let me also tell you a
little bit about what this is and what's
going on so this is a series you know
when I said that this is episode 72 we
have done 72 different sessions within
the series and it began way back in 2016
when we had session one at the
Brookfield Public Library uh back then
this was an in-person event which we
recorded and then put onto my YouTube
channel and many people commented and
watched the videos and had things to say
about them and in each session beyond
the first which was you know spent
talking about what's the nature of
fantasy science fiction speculative
fiction World building we would take an
author and a coherent world that spanned
multiple works and we'd explore that
world and we talk about the biography of
the author as well and how that
influence instead and maybe go into some
reviews and talk about their own
influence on other people and then we'd
go into the philosophical themes that
were involved in or sometimes even
explicitly talked about within the
novels or short stories whatever it is
that we were looking at we started with
Tolkien and we spanned everything going
up to
contemporary authors and all sorts of
people in between
so at a certain point during the covid
crisis we had to stop doing the
in-person sessions and we began doing it
in the format that you see now where
what will go on is I'll talk for about
90 minutes or so
um about different aspects of this it's
one big long video we typically Premiere
it and we do some live chat on the side
people can ask questions make comments
and then I respond to them and then
after that we'll have the more
interactive not quite face to face but
at least partly getting to see each
other's faces through a zoom session and
that's the way that we've been doing
these oh for you know about three years
at this point so uh we got a lot to talk
about with these really great shorts uh
eminently readable
novels so reflective of the world view
of Ballard himself and we're going to
talk about you know the different paths
that humanity and the planet that we
live on might be taking uh so we'll
start first by doing a little bit of
summary of the novels talking about what
is happening to the world in each of
them and why it's you know kind of scary
stuff but presented in a very
matter-of-fact Way by J.G Ballard
I think that with each of these three
World novels drowned World burning world
slash the drought and Crystal world we
can in fact talk about World building
but it's in a somewhat different sense
than what we are used to with say sci-fi
or fantasy novels where there's an
alternate world I mean it is in some
respects an alternate world to our own
in each of these there's some sort of
massive
ecological disaster that affects not
just Humanity not just the Flora and
Fauna but the entirety of the planet and
we could even say the solar system so
before we look at characters the theme
of Inner Space and psychology we should
actually look at the geography and the
changing climate of each of these and
when we begin with the drowned world
we learn from the very sentence soon it
would be too hot now that is quite a
statement rather ambiguous too hot per
se to hat for Humanity on this planet at
all or just too hot in massive zones of
the planet when we get introduced to the
main character Karen's
looking out from the hotel balcony
shortly after eight o'clock Karen's
watched the sun rise behind the dense
Groves of giant gymnosperms crowding
over the roofs of the abandoned
department stores 400 yards away on the
east side of the Lagoon and in that
sentence we have four elements that play
just a massive role we have the sun
rising we'll talk about why the sun is
so important in just a bit dense Groves
of giant gymnosperms ancient trees
ancient plants that are that are growing
now in crazy ways an abandoned
department store 400 yards away and the
east side of the Lagoon the water that
has been continually
rising and we go on even through the
mass of olive green fronds the real
Relentless power of the sun was plainly
tangible the blunt refracted Rays
drummed against his bare chest and
shoulders drawing out the first sweat
and he put on a pair of heavy sunglasses
to protect his eyes the solar disc was
no longer a well-defined sphere but a
wide expanding ellipse that fanned out
across the Eastern Horizon like a
colossal Fireball Its Reflection turning
the Dead lead in surface of the Lagoon
into a brilliant copper Shield by noon
less than four hours away the water
would seem to burn
so that's our first description
of this world and we find out
that something is going to be happening
soon Rigs and Cairns are talking to each
other and they're talking about the the
radio console and Riggs says do you ever
listen to that thing and Karen says no
that never there's any point we know the
news for the next three million years
and uh Riggs says oh you should turn it
on now and then you'll hear all sorts of
interesting things for example this
morning you would have heard that
exactly three days from now we're
packing up and leaving for good
apparently the water level is still
Rising all the work we've done has been
a total waste as I've always maintained
incidentally the American and Russian
units are being recalled as well
temperatures in the equator are up to
180 degrees now going up steadily and
the rain belts are continuous as high as
the 20th parallel there is more silt too
so this is describing the ongoing
succession of what's Happening we get
another interesting
um depiction here a little bit further
in
um
the bulk of the city had long since
vanished and only the steel supported
buildings of the central commercial and
financial areas had survived the
encroaching flood waters the brick
houses and single-story factories of the
suburbs had disappeared completely
between the drifting tides of silt where
these broke surface giant forests reared
up into the burning dull green Sky
smothering the former wheat fields of
temperate Europe and North America
impenetrable Mato Grosso sometimes 300
feet high they were a nightmare world of
competing Organic Farms returning
rapidly to their Paleozoic past and the
only Avenues of transit for the United
Nations military units were through the
Lagoon systems that had superimposed
themselves on the former cities
but even these were now being clogged
with silt and then submerged and so
Karen could remember the unending
succession of green Twilights that
settled behind them as he and Riggs
moved slowly northward across Europe
leaving one city after another now they
were to abandon yet another city despite
the massive construction of the main
commercial buildings it consisted of
little more than three principal lagoons
surrounded by a Nexus of small lakes 50
yards in diameter and a network of
narrow creeks and inlets which wound off
roughly following the original Street
plan of the city
out into the outlying jungle
so we've got a massively transformed
urbanized landscape that has now been
largely reclaimed
and we learn what has caused this again
very early on
here's how it's described the succession
of gigantic geophysical upheavals which
had transformed the earth's climate had
made their first impact some 60 or 70
years earlier a series of violent and
prolonged solar storms lasting several
years caused by a sudden instability in
the sun had enlarged the Van Allen belts
and diminished the Earth's gravitational
hold upon the outer layers of the
ionosphere
as these vanished into space depleting
the Earth's barrier against the full
impact of solar radiation temperatures
began to stop climb steadily the heated
atmosphere expanding outward into the
ionosphere where the cycle was completed
all over the world mean temperatures
Rose by a few degrees each year the
majority of tropical areas rapidly
became uninhabitable entire populations
migrating north or south from
temperatures of 130 and 140 degrees
over-tempered areas became tropical
Europe and North America sweltering
under continuous heat waves temperatures
rarely falling below 100 degrees
under the direction of the United
Nations
colonization began of the Antarctic
plateau and of the northern borders of
the Canadian and Russian continents and
he goes on and tells us
over this initial period of 20 years a
gradual adjustment of Life took place to
meet the altered climate a slackening of
the previous Temple was inevitable and
there was little spare energy available
to cut back the encroaching jungles of
the equatorial region Not only was the
growth of all platforms accelerated but
the higher levels of radioactivity
increased the rate at which mutations
occurred the first freak Botanical forms
appeared recalling the giant tree firms
of the carbon carbon ferrous period and
there was a drastic upsurge of all lower
plant and animal forms so we've got now
the Sun the ionosphere the Heat and now
we've got changing of the Flora
but it goes on the arrival of these
distant forbears was overlaid by the
second major geophysical upheaval
the continued heating of the atmosphere
had begun to melt the polar ice caps the
entrained ices of the Antarctic Plateau
broke and dissolved tens of thousands of
glaciers around the Arctic Circle from
Greenland and Northern Europe Russia
North America poured themselves into the
sea millions of Acres of permafrost
liquefied into gigantic Rivers so it's
not just the ice caps the permafrost in
the north as well
here again the rise of global water
levels would have been little more than
a few feet but the huge discharging
channels carried with them billions of
tons of topsoil mass of Deltas formed at
their mouths extending the Continental
coastlines damming up the oceans the
their effective spread shrank from
two-thirds of the world's area to only
slightly more than half driving the
submerged silt before them the new Seas
completely altered the shape and
Contours of the continents the
Mediterranean contracted into a system
of Inland Lakes the British Isles was
linked again with northern France the
middle west of the United States filled
by the Mississippi as it drained the
Rocky Mountains became an enormous Gulf
opening into the Hudson Bay while the
Caribbean Sea was transformed into a
desert of silt and Salt Flats Europe
became a system of giant lagoons
centered on the principal low-lying
cities is inundated by the silt carried
Southward by the expanding Rivers so
what an imaginative
Vista for the world I won't even say the
new world the altered world the going
back to previous conditions world that
Humanity now has to survive within
moving northward moving Southward
he goes on and says during the next 30
Years the poll word migration of
populations continued a few fortified
cities defied the rising water levels
and encroaching jungles building
elaborate sea walls around their
perimeters but one by one these were
breached only within the former Arctic
and Antarctic circles was life tolerable
the oblique incidence of the sun's Rays
provided a shield against the more
powerful radiation cities on higher
ground and mountainous areas near the
equator had been abandoned despite their
cooler temperatures because of the
diminished atmospheric protection
so the only consolation to this as he's
going to tell us in the next paragraph
is the decline in mammalian fertility
very few children are being born
and the Earth can no longer sustain much
human life just in order not to take up
too much time
only bring up one other
short uh
peace here
so this is one more description early on
in the work like an immense putrescent
sore the jungle lay exposed be below the
open hatchway of the helicopter giant
grows of gymnosperms stretched in dense
clumps among the rooftops of the
submerged buildings smothering the white
rectangular outlines here and there in
old concrete water tower protruded from
the morass or the remains of a makeshift
Jetty still floated along the husk of a
collapsing office block overgrown with
feathery acacias and flowering tamarisks
so that we could go on and on with this
but we don't I don't think we need to I
think you've got the picture of what the
drowned world looks like
very few places remaining for human
beings and now they're supposed to press
on northward
the burning world or the drought as it
comes to be known later on with slightly
different chapter Arrangements
situates us in a world where as you can
guess water becomes the main resource
that is further and further lacking and
in this case it is because of human
interventions in the environment as
we'll talk about and all the action
takes place near the coastal areas and
so we get this interesting description
happening early on shielding his eyes
from the sunlight Ransom surveyed the
silent banks of the river as they wound
Westward to the City of Mount Royal five
miles away for a week he'd been out on
the lake sailing the houseboat among the
draining creeks and mud flats as he
waited for the evacuation of the city to
end
after the closure of the hospital on
Mount Royal he intended to leave for the
coast but at the last minute decided to
spend a few final days on the lake
before it vanished for good now and then
between the humps of damp mud emerging
from the center of the lake he'd seen
the instant span of the motor Bridge
across the river though windows with
thousands of cars and trucks flashing
like jeweled lances as they set off on
the coast road for the South but for the
most part he had been alone suspended
like the houseboat above the dissolving
glass of the water time had seemed be
calmed and then by then the lake wants a
stretch of Open Water 30 miles in length
had subsided into a series of small
pools and channels separated by the
banks of draining mud so what we see
here what he calls the slow
transformation of the lake wide sheets
of water contracted first into shallow
lagoons and then into Maze of creeks the
wet Dunes of the lake bed seemed to
emerge From Another Dimension right
there are slopes of mud he's steering
the houseboat to the entrance of the
river along stranded yachts and fishing
boats and everything has been
essentially
abandoned now what caused this we
actually get an explanation here
uh in part one the worldwide drought now
in its fifth month was the culmination
of a series of extended droughts that
had taken place with increasing
frequency all over the globe during the
previous decade 10 years earlier a
critical shortage of world foodstuffs
had occurred when the seasonal rainfall
expected in a number of important
agricultural areas had failed to
materialize
one by one areas as far apart as
Saskatchewan on the Loire Valley
Kazakhstan and The Madras tea country
were turned into arid dust basins the
following months brought little more
than a few inches of rain and after two
years these farmlands were totally
devastated once their populations had
resettled themselves elsewhere these new
deserts were abandoned for good
the continued appearance of more and
more such areas on the map and the added
difficulties of making good the world's
Food Supplies led to the first attempts
at some form of global weather control
surveyed by the U.N food and agriculture
organization showed that everywhere
River levels and water tables were
falling the two and a half million
square miles drained by the Amazon and
shrunk to less than half this area
scores of its tributaries had dried up
completely and aerial surveys discovered
that much of the former rainforest was
already dry and petrified at Khartoum in
Lower Egypt the White Nile was 20 feet
below its mean level 10 years earlier
and lower Outlets were bored in the
concrete barrage of the dam at Aswan
despite worldwide attempts at Clouds
ceding the amounts of rainfall continued
to diminish the seating operations
finally ended when it was obvious that
Not only was there no rain but there
were no clouds at this point detention
switched to the ultimate source of
rainfall the ocean surfaced it needed
only the briefest scientific examination
to show that here were the origins of
the drought so we have this cataclysmic
drought and reduction of water tables
worldwide resulting in massive
population dislocations and a major
disruption of the Food Systems
throughout the world what's causing this
well he goes on to tell us
covering the offshore Waters of the
world's oceans to a distance of about a
thousand miles from the coast was a thin
but resilient monomolecular film formed
from a complex of saturated long chain
polymers generated within the sea from
the vast quantities of industrial wastes
discharged into the ocean basins during
the previous 50 years this tough oxygen
permeable membrane lay on the water air
water interface and prevented almost all
evaporation of surface water into the
air space above
although the structure of these polymers
was quickly identified no means was
found of removing them the saturated
linkages produced in the perfect organic
bath of the sea were completely
non-reactive and formed an intact seal
broken only when the water was violently
Disturbed fleets of trawlers and Naval
craft equipped with rotating flails
began to ply up and down the Atlantic
and Pacific coasts of North America and
along the seaboards of Western Europe
but without any long-term effects the
removal of the entire surface water
provided only a temporary respite the
film quickly replaced Itself by lateral
extension from the surrounding surface
recharged by precipitation from the
reservoir below the mechanism of
formation of these polymers remained
obscure but millions of tons of highly
reactive Industrial Waste unwanted
petroleum fractions contaminated
catalysts and solvents were still being
vented in the sea where they mingled
with the waste of atomic power stations
and sewage schemes out of this Brew the
sea had constructed a skin no thicker
than a few atoms but sufficiently strong
to devastate the lands it once irrigated
so this is the causality and it turns
out there's not a lot that human beings
can actually do about this except suffer
the effects and he goes on to call it
this act of Retribution by the Sea and
said it had always impressed Ransom by
its simple Justice
right so you know there's there's a
nothing going on there are cumulus
clouds burdened like Madonna's with Cool
Rain which still formed over the Central
Ocean surfaces
but they would always deposit their
cargo into the dry unsaturated air above
the sealed offshore Waters never onto
the crying land
and the land becomes more and more and
more dry the water places are eventually
going away later on they talk about
following the residue of a river as it
winds across a lake the channel narrowed
sometimes to little no more than 15 feet
in width at others dividing into thin
streams that disappeared among the dunes
and mud Banks stranded Yachts lay on the
slopes streaked with the scum lines of
the receding water the bed of the lake
almost drained was now an inland Beach
of white Dunes covered with pieces of
blanched Timber and Driftwood along the
bank the dried Marsh Grass formed a
burnt Palisade that is the
landscape where formerly the lake Escape
that they have
now there is something interesting that
we find out later on
um and it has to do with waves and
they're talking about perhaps there will
be a tidal wave tonight once every three
or four years in response to some
distant submarine earthquake a huge wave
would inundate the coast the third and
last of these some two years earlier it
swept across the Salt Flats an hour
before Dawn reaching to the very margins
of the beach the hundreds of shacks and
dwellings among the dunes had been
destroyed by the waste high water the
reservoir pools where they keep the
water for themselves uh washed away in a
few seconds staggering about in the
sliding salt they'd watched everything
they owned carried away as the Luminous
water swilled around the wreck ships the
exhausted Beach dwellers had climbed up
to the sawtips and sat there until dawn
then in the first light they'd seen a
fabulous spectacle the entire stretch of
the draining Salt Flats was covered with
the expiring forms of thousands tens of
thousands of stranded fish every pool
alive with crabs and shrimps the ensuing
Blood Feast as the Galls dived and
screamed around the flashing Spears had
rekindled the remaining survivors for
three weeks they moved from pool to pool
and Gorge themselves like beasts
performing and obscene Eucharist
right so they're they're living fairly
close to Nature you might say
um in part three we find that Ransom
wants to follow along this River uh
dried up now the flat deck of the river
stretched away to the north at its
margins were the remains of the stone
embankment formed a ragged Windbreak the
dunes had gathered together in high
drifts and these Define the wind winding
course of the drained bed Beyond The
Dunes is the desert floor littered with
fragments of dried mud like shards of
pottery at intervals the stump of a tree
marked the distance of a concealed Ridge
from the river or a metal windmill stood
guard over a dried up Creek in the
coastal Hills the upper slopes of the
valley had flowered with a few clumps of
hearty Gore sustained by the drifts of
spray but 10 miles from the sea the
desert was arid the surface crumbling
beneath the foot into a fine white
powder
the party moved at a steady Pace along
the drained bed and why are they doing
this because Ransom is convinced that
there must be water within 30 or 20
miles of the coast probably released
from a spring or an underground river
why because there's a lion prowling
around in the desert and so they're on
this perhaps exotic uh adventure of
going further Inland to try to find this
water source
and this is an interesting
a novel of these three because as
opposed to the drowned world where
things aren't going to get better and
humanity is receded to the to the polar
regions and as opposed to the crystal
World which we're going to look at in
just a moment where again prospects are
not good
this one ends on a slightly different
note
so this is the last few paragraphs
although it was not yet noon the sun
seemed to be receding into the sky and
the air was becoming colder to his
surprise you noticed he no longer cast
any shadow on the sand as if he had come
at last completed his journey across the
margins of the inner landscape he'd
carried in his mind for so long the
light failed and the air grew darker the
dust was dull and opaque the crystals in
its surface dead and clouded an immense
Paul of Darkness lay over the dunes as
if the whole of the exterior world were
losing its existence
it was sometime later that he failed to
notice it had started to rain so
there is a possibility of the earth
returning to something like what we call
normalcy you know a weather pattern
where clouds actually form and blot out
the Sun and then Reign upon the land is
it hopeful it's difficult to tell
because we don't have enough information
as the work ends but this is somewhat
different than the other two world books
that we're looking at here
the third novel The Crystal world
doesn't begin as the other two do with
us already in the middle of Crisis
rather it begins with an enigma
something
unexplained some questions that are
being raised as this doctor is trying to
make his way into Cameroon and we begin
with a letter that he's received this is
DR Sanders from Suzanne and she tells
them at last we are here the forest is
the most beautiful in Africa a house of
jewels I can barely find words to
describe our Wonder each morning as we
look out across the slopes still have
hidden by the Mist but glistening like
Saint Sophia each bow a jeweled
semi-dome indeed Max says I'm becoming
excessively Byzantine I wear my hair to
my waist even at the clinic in effect a
Melancholy expression right and it
concludes by saying
they walk through the dark forest with
crowns of light on their head it sounds
very metaphorical right oh you know it's
a beautiful Dawn with you know beads of
water condensed on the foliage and it's
like Jewels but as we're going to find
out it's not really the case
now he Sanders is trying to get to Mount
Royal and the clerk at the reception
desk is evasive right he says that
um doctor you understand there is no
boat the service has been suspended and
then Sandra says okay what about the
railway or the bus service there must be
some transport to Mount Royal and the
clerk says there's no Railway diamonds
you know doctor not difficult to
transport maybe you can make inquiries
about the bus and he's finding it more
and more difficult
to get to Mount Royal eventually he's
talking to the African charge captain
and he says you know why the censorship
going on here why blocking things off I
find there's no means of getting to
Mount Royal in an atmosphere of mystery
surrounds the whole place
Captain nodded pondering over the letter
on his desk occasionally prodded the
tissue with a steel ruler as though he
were examining the Pressed Petals of
some rare and perhaps poisonous Blossom
I understand doctor it's difficult for
you and Sandra says but why is the
censorship in Force at all is a rebel
group captured the minds the captain
shook his head I assure you Doctor
there's no political trouble at Mount
Royal in fact there's hardly anyone
there at all
most of the workers have left
the captain stood up and went over to
the window he pointed to the dark Fringe
Of The Jungle crowding over the rooftops
of the Native quarter the forest doctor
do you see it frightens them it's so
black and heavy all the time
in confidence I can explain there is a
new kind of plant disease beginning in
the forest near Mount Royal what do you
mean Sanders cut in a virus disease like
tobacco Mosaic yes that's it the captain
nodded encouragingly though he seemed to
have little idea of what he was talking
about anyway it's not poisonous but we
have to take precautions some experts
will look at the forests and sandals to
libreville you understand it takes time
and then uh Sandra says will I be able
to go to Mount Royal the Army hasn't
closed off the area no the captain
insisted you are quite free just small
areas you see it's not dangerous your
friends are all right we don't want
people rushing there trying to make
trouble and then he says well how long
has this been going on and the captain
says
about a year longer perhaps at first no
one bothered
so what's actually going on well there's
some hints when people are bringing you
know these jewel encrusted crystallized
pieces of fungus and Flora and even
crosses into the marketplace but a
little bit later
we find that um
Sanders is having a conversation with
radic and Radix says
um
it seems that the business here in your
own specialty are very similar and in a
way one is the dark side of the other
I'm thinking of the silver scales of
leprosy that give the disease its name
now tell me have you seen any of the
crystallized objects some flowers and
leaves Sanders decided not to mention
the dead man that morning who had been
found crystallized
so
um radic says this has been going on for
some time nearly a year in fact first it
was costume jewelry then small carvings
and holy objects recently there's been
quite a trade here natives were taking
the cheap carvings into the active Zone
leaving there overnight going back the
next day for them unfortunately some of
the stuff the jewelry in particular had
a tendency to dissolve
and they tried it with diamonds and the
Diamonds themselves would you know Chris
crystallize around them and then
dissolve
and then radic goes on and I says I can
tell you in confidence of course this is
not the only affected area in the world
so now we see that it's happening in
other places
at this moment at least two other sites
exist one in the Florida Everglades the
other in the pripit marches of the
Soviet Union
naturally both are under intensive
investigation
and
nobody quite knows exactly what's going
on
um but they have some theories they're
talking about you know a satellite and
then the mount Hubble observatory in the
United States seeing distant galaxies
efflarescing
Caitlyn believes this is the Hubble
effect as they call it closer to a
cancer than anything else and about as
curable
an actual proliferation of the subatomic
identity of all matter it's as if a
sequence of displaced but identical
images of the same object were being
produced by refraction through a prism
but with the element of time replacing
the role of life so there we're starting
to get the the beginning of an
explanation for what is happening within
this world that will sooner or later
become Crystal
and we're you know going to get some
interesting descriptions about what is
happening uh later on so for example a
helicopter crashes because the blades
crystallized while it's near the trees
and they go on uh looking radic sanders
and and as men going through the trees
they were soon within the body of the
forest and had entered in an enchanted
world the crystal trees around them were
hung with glass like trellises of moss
the air was markedly cooler as if
everything was sheathed in ice but a
ceaseless play of light poured through
the canopy overhead
the process of crystallization was more
advanced the fences along the road were
so heavily encrusted they formed a
continuous Palisade a white Frost at
least six inches thick on either side of
the palings the few houses between the
trees glistened like wedding cakes
they're white roofs and chimneys
transformed into exotic minarets and
Baroque domes
on a lawn of Green Glass Spurs a child's
tricycle glittered like a Faberge gem
the wheels start into brilliant Jasper
crowns so what is happening everything
is getting covered
transformed into
crystalline structures
now there's a further description about
what is actually going on a bit later in
this letter in the second part
where um
Sanders is writing and he says all this
my dear Paul the very absence of
surprise confirms my belief that this
illumin forest in some way reflects an
earlier period of our lives and we're
going to come back to that in a bit it
is perhaps our unique achievements as
Lords of this creation to have brought
about the separation of time and space
we've given to each a separate value a
distinct measure of their own which now
Define and bind us like the length and
breadth of a coffin to resolve them
again is the greatest aim of Natural
Science
as you and I have seen Paul in our work
on the virus with its semi-animate
crystalline existence half in and half
out of our own time stream
as if intersecting it at an angle
often I think that in our microscopes
examining the tissue of those poor
lepers in our hospital we were looking
upon a minuscule replica of the world I
was to meet later in the forest slopes
near
Mount Royal
then he goes on and he says Paul it
seems obvious the real crisis is long
past tucked away on the back page of the
same issue of Paris Suarez the short
report on the sighting of another double
Galaxy by observers of the Hubble
Institute on Mount Palomar the news is
summarized in less than a dozen lines
and without comment although the
implication is inescapable that yet
another focal area has been set up
somewhere on the surface of the Earth in
the temple-filled jungles of Cambodia or
the haunted Amber forests of the Chilean
Highland but it's still only a year
since the Mount Palomar astronomers
identify the first double galaxy in the
constellation Andromeda the great oblet
diadem that is probably the most
beautiful object in the physical
Universe the island Galaxy
M31 he goes on and he says we now know
that it is time
which is responsible for the
transformation
the recent discovery of antimatter in
the universe inevitably involves the
conception of anti-time as the foresight
of this negatively charged Continuum
where anti-particle and particle Collide
they not only destroy their own physical
identities but their opposing time
values eliminate each other subtracting
from the universe another quantum from
its total store of time
it is random discharges of this type set
off by the creation of anti-galaxies in
space which have led to the depletion of
the Time store available to the
materials of our own solar system just
as a supersaturated solution will
discharge itself into a crystalline Mass
so the supersaturation of matter in our
Continuum leads to its appearance in a
parallel spatial Matrix as more and more
time leaks away the process of
supersaturation continues the original
atoms and molecules now here's the
important part
producing spatial replicas of themselves
substance without mass in an attempt to
increase their foothold on existence
the process
is theoretically Without End and it may
be possible eventually for a single atom
to produce an infinite number of
duplicates of itself and so fill the
entire universe
from which simultaneously all time is
expired an ultimate macrocosmic zero
beyond the wildest dreams of Plato and
Democritus so
what's going on now well I mean we don't
necessarily have to buy this explanation
this is Sanders speculating Sanders is
not himself a physicist he's a medical
doctor
but it is quite an interesting
speculation isn't it this goes Way
Beyond just human beings screwing up the
climate in some way or some random
solar system event this is the entire
universe now which is gradually becoming
inhospitable to human life
we go on a little bit further and I just
want to read a few more passages we
talked about a downed helicopter
at first they passed the aircraft lying
like an emblazoned fossil and a small
Hollow to the left of their path DR
Sanders failed to recognize it
Sanders remembered the helicopter
plunging into the forest half a mile
from the inspection site the four
Twisted blades veined and frosted like
the wings of a giant dragonfly had
already been overgrown by the trellises
of crystals hanging downward from the
nearby trees the fuselage had blossomed
into an enormous translucent Jewel in
whose solid depth like emblematic
Knights mounted in the base of a
medieval ring Stone the two pilots sat
Frozen at their controls their silver
helmets gave off an endless Fountain of
Light
and they find radic there
neither quite alive nor quite dead
um
towards the end
we get uh another interesting
description the crystallization of the
forest was now almost complete only the
jewels in the cross Jewels allow you to
actually like keep the crystallization
at Bay allowed Sanders to make his way
through the vaults between the trees
holding the shaft in his hands he moved
the cross piece along the trellises that
hung everywhere like Webb's of ice
looking for the weaker panels that would
dissolve in the light when he reached
for the river he searched for the bridge
he had found when he entered the forest
for the second time but the Prismatic
surface extended away in a wide Bend
it's light obliterating the few
landmarks he might otherwise have
recognized
so we get a world in which you can't
even really get your bearings anymore
and we I'm going to bring this to a
conclusion with just another thing that
he's writing in a letter he says
um
I know now I shall one day return to the
forest at Mount Royal each night the
fractured disc of the echo satellite
passes overhead Illuminating the
midnight sky like a silver Chandelier
and I am convinced Paul
that the sun itself
has begun to a floor us
at Sunset when its disk has failed by
the Crimson dust it seems to be crossed
by a distinctive latticework a vast
porticules that will one day spread
outward to the planets and the Stars
halting them in their courses
Cosmic transformation not only of the
Earth
but of the solar system itself
and will it be any room for our human
beings yes but only as crystallized in
this world that is hinted at yet to come
with an author like JG Ballard who has
so much to say I think it's quite useful
to look at some of the interviews that
he's done over the years telling us
about his writing and thinking and
research processes what it is that he's
trying to do and how he conceives of his
own work and I think that one of the
interviews to begin with
is that which he did with Charles Char
Murray in it he said now this is a kind
of retrospective
even though the drowned world was
written over 20 years ago it should be
put in its context as the first Inner
Space novel Innerspace was the flag
which I nailed to my Mast and the
drowned World written in 62 or whenever
it was is literally the first Inner
Space novel up to that point
catastrophe stories were being done on a
very literal level as adventure stories
but the psychological Adventure became
the subject matter for me
he goes on and he clarifies
if you look at the book marketing's
Council list you'll see that John
windham's the day of the trifids is
there now it's a fine novel a classic
example of the English kind of home
countries catastrophe fiction a very
polite Society where all kinds of
private obsessions are kept firmly
buttoned down and people struggle in the
face of an external threat as they did
during the Battle of Britain or as we're
led to believe that they did during the
Battle of Britain my novel turns that
all upside down
the hero Embraces the catastrophe as a
means by which he can express and
fulfill his own nature pursue his own
mythology to the end whatever that may
be
he can accept the logic of his own
personality and run that logic right
down to the end of the road that's a
different approach that's what the
drowned world is about that's what
nearly all my fiction is about now isn't
that an interesting set of observations
that he's making so we've got first of
all the attention to Inner Space what is
Inner Space it's the psychology of the
characters not just in terms of their
motivation but in terms of their
understanding of who they themselves are
and how they relate to other human
beings and to the environment that
they're living in is a catastrophe
indeed a catastrophe it's not a
tolkenian you catastrophe it's rather
something different offering Divergent
possibilities of figuring things out a
chain changing valuations changing what
it is that you are up to
so that's a very interesting
set of observations that he's giving
there and he's he's tracing a kind of
development right going away from
catastrophe is providing a kind of
backdrop for a certain moralization and
a kind of coming of age or adventure
story as opposed to something rich or
something deeper or something
Starker in an interview with George
Macbeth he's going to talk about science
fiction
and Ballard says I don't regard myself
as a writer of what most people would
call modern science fiction
which is predominantly American even
though much of it has been written by
English writers modern American Science
Fiction grew out of magazines such as
the Popular Mechanics of the 30s it's an
extrovert optimistic literature of
Technology
I think the new science fiction which
other people other other people apart
from myself are now beginning to write
is introverted
possibly pessimistic rather than
optimistic much less certain of its own
territory there's a tremendous
confidence that radiates through all
modern American Science Fiction of the
period 1930 to 1960 the certainty that
Science and Technology can solve all
problems
this is not the dominant form of Science
Fiction now I think that science fiction
is becoming something much more
speculative much less convinced about
the magic of Science and the moral
authority of science there's far more
caution on the part of the new writers
than there was so that's an interesting
point then we have a longer excerpt from
an interview that he carried out that
I'm going to read only parts of with
um
Yannick storm
so again Ballard Begins by talking about
science fiction sort of tracing its
history he says modern American Science
Fiction of the 1940s and 1950s is a
popular literature of Technology it came
out of American Mass magazines and all
that optimism about science and
technology have found in those days
the science fiction written in those
days came out of all this optimism that
science was going to remake the world
then came Hiroshima and Auschwitz and
the image of science completely changed
people became very suspicious of science
but sci-fi didn't change you still found
this optimistic literature the Heinlein
Asimov Clark type of attitude towards
the possibilities of science which was
completely false
then he goes on and says in the 1950s
during the testing of the hydrogen bomb
you could see that science was getting
to be something much closer to Magic
also science fiction was then identified
with the idea of outer space
by and large that was the image most
people had of Science Fiction the
spaceship the alien planet and that
didn't make much sense to me it seemed
like they were ignoring what I felt was
the most important area what I called
and I used the term for the first time
seven years ago Inner Space
which was the meeting ground between the
inner world of the mind and the outer
world of reality Inner Space you see in
the paintings of the surrealists MOX
Aaron's Dolly tange and shiroko now
notice Inner Space is not just going
Within
Ballard is saying something really
important here Inner Space is the
meeting ground between the inner world
of the mind and the outer world of
reality so it by its very nature is not
just the inner as opposed to the outer
it's the interface between the two of
them
now he goes on and he says that these
surrealists are painters of Inner Space
and I felt science fiction should
explore that area the area where the
mind impinges on the outside world and
not just deal in fantasy this is the
trouble with sci-fi in the early 50s it
was becoming
fantasy it wasn't a serious realistic
fiction anymore so I started writing I'd
written three novels in something like
70 short stories over the last 10 years
I think that perhaps in only one story
there's a spaceship it's just mentioned
passing
so he goes on and he's asked about
landscapes
are his landscape symbolic and he says
well they're not real in the sense that
I don't write naturalistically about the
present day though in the latest group
of stories I've started to write the
stories that I call condensed novels I'm
using the landscape of the present day
and he goes on a bit more and he's asked
about about science and coming back to
this he says you know I'm not hostile to
science itself I think that scientific
activity is about the only mature
activity there is what I'm hostile to is
the image of science that people have
it becomes a magic wand in people's
minds that will conjure up Marvels a
kind of Aladdin's Lantern it
oversimplifies things much too
conveniently science now in fact is the
largest producer of fiction isn't that
an interesting
Paradox a way of playing off of
dichotomy science all facts you know
theories that we can prove right
empirically fiction over here and
Ballard is saying no no no no no
science used to be like that but
nowadays things have changed he's noting
something that Nietzsche for example was
already
attuned to back in the late 1800s that
in the work of science itself it
undermines its own credibility values
and leaves things kind of hanging in a
void right and in many respects it's not
that science doesn't work or technology
doesn't work but it is
viewed in a magical fantasyical sense so
he goes on and he says that 100 years
ago or even 50 years ago science took
its raw material from nature a scientist
worked out the boiling point of a gas or
the distance of stars away from the
earth whereas nowadays particularly in
the social psychological Sciences the
raw material of science is a fiction
invented by The Sciences you know they
work out why people chew gum or
something of this kind so the Sciences
are spewing out an enormous amount of
fiction there are major producers of
fiction it's not the writers anymore
and we might say in our own time and
Ballard also realizes this that you know
business the marketing Industries
technology they're all churning out
stuff that is
science e but isn't really old school
science and is a kind of fiction that
happens to be persuasive and catch on or
doesn't if people don't buy into it
then he's asked about the new wave
and he says well I am the new wave of
Science Fiction I think it's only at the
beginning having knocked my own head
against a brick wall for 10 years you
know it's only now that people begin to
accept I'm not a deliberate fool which a
lot of people thought I was when I first
started writing
um and he goes on and talks about
different kinds of Science Fiction and
whether these people will stay in
science fiction long enough to
consolidate the new wave or whether as I
think a lap and they'll just move out of
Science Fiction altogether and beginning
right begin writing a speculative
fiction that doesn't know anything to
science fiction I don't know and then
he's asked do you consider yourself a
science fiction writer and he says
not in the same sense that Isaac Asimov
or Arthur C Clarke are science fiction
writers
strictly speaking I regard myself as a
science fiction writer in the way that
surrealism is also a scientific art
in a sense as a moth Heinlein and the
Masters of American sci-fi are not
really writing of science at all they're
writing about a set of imaginary ideas
which are conveniently labeled science
they're writing about the future they're
writing a kind of fantasy fiction about
the future closer to the Western and the
Thriller but it really has nothing to do
with science I studied medicine
chemistry physiology physics and I
worked for about five years on a
scientific journal the idea that a
magazine like astounding or analog as
it's now called has anything to do with
the Sciences is ludicrous it has nothing
to do with the science you have to only
to pick up a journal like nature or any
scientific journal and you can see that
science belongs in a completely
different world
Freud pointed out that you have to
distinguish between analytic activity
which by and large is what the Sciences
are in synthetic activities which is
what the Arts are the trouble with the
Heinlein Asimov type of Science Fiction
is that it's completely synthetic
and he says Freud also said synthetic
activities are a sign of immaturity and
that's where I think classical sci-fi
falls down
and then he's asked about the
development of his own writing
and he says it's been a process of
evolution rather than Revolution and now
here we get to the catastrophe novels I
wrote a novel called the drought which
is my second novel after the drowned
world it was a novel about desert areas
I noticed while I was writing it I was
beginning to explore the geometry of a
very abstract kind of landscape and very
abstract relationships between the
characters I went on from there to write
a short story which I called the
terminal Beach which is set on and at
wetak the island in the Pacific where
the h-bomb was tested there again I was
trying to look at the characters and
events in a very abstract almost Cubist
way I was isolating aspects of character
isolating aspects of the narrative
rather like a scientific investigator
taking apart a strange machine to see
how it works now I think that applies to
all three of the catastrophe novels
myself which is uh quite quite
interesting yeah
a little bit uh later on in that
interview he's going to talk about the
um
what's going on in the 1960s
and he uh then talks about the end of
the Cold War and he says that things are
becoming more and more and more fiction
a media landscape if you like people's
lives are getting more and more
controlled by what I call fiction and he
says by fiction I mean anything invented
for imaginative purposes so for an
example you don't buy an airline ticket
you don't just buy transportation to the
south of France or Spain what you buy is
the image of a particular Airline the
kind of mini skirts the hostesses are
wearing on that airline in fact Airlines
in America are selling themselves on
that sort of thing
also the sort of homes people buy for
themselves the way they furnish their
houses even the way that they talk the
friends they have everything is becoming
fictionalized they're for given that
reality is now a fiction it's not
necessary for the writer to invent the
fiction The Writer's relationship with
reality is completely the other way
around
it's the writer's job
to find the reality to invent the
reality not to invent the fiction the
Fiction's already there
so this is quite interesting as an
observation if we think about some of
the implications of that for these
particular Global catastrophe
novels what is Ballard actually doing in
these long before he starts doing you
know things like crash and atrocity
exhibition
if we buy into this formula that read it
one more time the
writer's job is to find the reality to
invent the reality not to invent the
fiction because the fiction is already
there
we live in fictions of what the
environment is what the world is how our
Global and local processes work what our
lives are
but those are all fiction and the
reality is something that can be
stripped away that can be discovered as
we change parameters the significant
parameters for instance the oceans no
longer allowing water to be evaporated
into the air in a great drought
occurring or the sun becoming hotter and
the world becoming you know more watery
and more more hot and Mankind having to
navigate or in the crystal world
something altogether different crystals
forming whether we like them or not in
areas and encrusting things taking them
over uh turning them turning their very
molecular composition not inside out but
in different ways all of those are we
could say realities within the novels
that Ballard is writing for for us and
trying to get us away from the fictions
that otherwise dominate our life so he's
doing a very interesting kind of
speculative fiction here do we want to
call it science fiction that's it
depends on what we mean by that term
Ballard himself is comfortable enough
with saying yes I write science fiction
just not that kind of Science Fiction
and it might turn into something else
quite different down the line
there is a pretty large secondary
literature out there on JG Ballard and
his Works in general and even some that
are particularly focused on these three
novels of sometimes they're called clifi
or catastrophe novels environmental
novels and so I wanted to bring you some
of the most interesting insights that
I've come across that I think we can
chew on a bit so the first one is from a
piece by Bruce Franklin called what are
we to make of J.G Ballard's apocalypse
and he tells us that JG Ballard and the
other creators of an apocalyptic science
fiction Thrive because of certain
conditions of the present era and he
says that you know from the outset we
must understand the enormous significant
of Science Fiction and the most
developed capitalist Nations so science
fiction is a means for for reaching a
lot of people
and he says that
Ballard is not some Oddity or aberration
but a representative anglo-american
intellectual who's chosen to write
science fiction because it's the most
suitable vehicle
for the expression of ideas he holds in
common with many other anglo-american
individuals and then he says something
very interesting here
Ballard makes little pretense his
fantasies of the death of the world or
the human species are scientific
plausible or even possible the forms of
his catastrophes are in fact mutually
contradictory there may be too many
people or too few people the world may
get too dry too wet the environment May
suddenly inexplicably begin to move too
fast or almost as suddenly and just as
inexplicably begin to congeal the end
may come about through hydrogen bombs
solipsism suicide ceaseless urbanism or
a worldwide auto get in of car crashes
even within a single work there's often
no consistent explanation of why the
cataclysm is occurring other than some
vague
pseudoscientific Theory presented like a
magician's patter and perhaps offered to
satisfy the conventional expectations of
the readers of Science Fiction
and then he says you know the novels
seemed to me to fall neatly into two
groupings the early novels of worldwide
physical catastrophe that's what we're
interested in and then the later novels
of psychological destruction of course
there's plenty of psychological havoc in
the early novels but unifying all of
these novels is the theme of the global
catastrophe as an external projection of
a deranged inner
landscape so I think that's the key
thing in this essay and then it goes on
to talk about the you know the drowned
world for example uh he says it presents
the characteristic structural conception
of Ballard's fiction just as the drowned
Planet projects an inner landscape so
the body and psyche of the protagonists
recapitulate in microcosm the world of
nature the sun is an almost conscious
power is burning off the ionosphere and
reclaiming the planet for itself this
the Earth is becoming a steaming sea
mingled with swamp and jungle artifacts
of civilization are being inundated
inundated by water and taken over by
reptiles and the most sensitive human
beings find their own minds booming to
rhythms of the Sun as they drift back
into a primibial and pre-conscious World
it seems quite correct right
and he goes on and he says you know my
my criticism of Ballard
as he doesn't go far enough down below
the unconscious to the sources of the
alienation self-destruction and Mass
Slaughter of our age he therefore
remains incapable of understanding the
alternative to these death forces the
global movement towards human Liberation
which constitutes the distinguishing
characteristic of our epic the real
Nemesis of militarism exploitation the
rape of the environment is not the
insane overloaded man who's seeking to
be free by obliterating the entire world
nor the suicidal quietest like you know
Karen's in the drowned World Ransom and
the drought or Edward Sanders in the
crystal world so some interesting
thoughts there good amuse Bush then we
have uh Joe militia's dry thoughts in a
dry season where he talks about Ballard
becoming famous because of the
publication of four catastrophe novels
win flood drought and crystallization
now of course we know that the wind won
uh Ballard really doesn't even like that
that book so that's part of why we're
not looking at it and then he goes on
and he says of the four
the drought the burning world and it's
an original American version is perhaps
the most notable achievement
um more plausible than the drowned World
less schematic than the crystal world
it's interesting for it's constructing a
world based on surrealist painting a
world that is also a symbolic reflection
of the mental condition of the book's
protagonist such qualities now notice
we're talking about genre here
may seem more to belong to Fantasy than
sci-fi but it's also interesting for its
relations to one of the classic
categories of sci-fi the apocalypse
story
no doubts all sci-fi may be called
apocalyptic if one's definition is Broad
enough to include any radical changes
from present conditions and then he goes
on and he says you know we can actually
distinguish various categories of the
disaster novel and then think about how
Ballard stuff fits into this so here's
the distinctions he's proposing
disasters unshacked versus disasters
averted right
um
so a classic Model HG Wells the were the
War of the Worlds right the disaster is
averted Michael crichton's The Andromeda
Strain well ballards are not averted um
disaster is unchecked disasters in the
process of happening versus those having
happened long ago and he goes on and he
says you know for post-disaster novels
can be subdivided according to the theme
fall of Man By the Waters of Babylon
survival of the fittest degeneration of
the species and he says if we think
about what's going on in Ballard so the
the drought begins with the disaster
underway the second part of the novel
portraying primitive social institutions
in which survivors organize on the Great
Salt Dunes is part of the same tradition
of disaster long past fiction like
Miller's A Canticle for Leibowitz
success this is a third versus failure
in coping with disaster right so you
know we have paradigms like Robinson
Caruso and Lord of the Flies as being
two the first celebrates man's ability
to survive or Prevail in extreme
conditions like in the Wind from nowhere
while the second per trades mob ruler
sinking to Bistro levels as in the
drought
um or you know others and perhaps we
should include a third possibility the
impassive Chronicle of biological
spectacle like stapleton's first and
last and first men
fourth various types of disaster right
there's all different sorts that we can
divide it into now notice he says
in all Ballard's novels except the
drought the catastrophe is outside of
human control as it is in many tales of
plagues alien invasions and
meteorological or geological
disturbances
and then we can divide natural disasters
further if we want to but the drought is
really about our own screwing up the
environment and then paying the costs
and then finally the fifth one causes of
disaster that are of central interest to
the writer versus those merely providing
a situation the writer wants to develop
most novels of man-made disaster are
actively interested in the Cause right
because we're warning like he says
against War ecological Decay or they may
more sophisticatedly explore the Dark
Side of human nature some causes might
be of interest in terms of scientific
speculation
uh exactly what effects could sunspots
have on the Van Allen belt in which the
reason for World crystallization is of
organic importance to every aspect of
the novel so interesting breakdown here
and we can see where did the Ballard's
stories fit into this this schema
uh we got a good uh little thing from
Jason Heller's review of The Crystal
World the third of these uh apocalyptic
novels that Ballard actually likes
and it says JG Ballard is often
considered the Godfather of clifi
climate fiction the legendary British
authors cataclysmic novels of the 1960s
including the burning world the drown
world the wind from nowhere imagine the
nightmarish results of a trio of climate
related disasters but they're all pulpy
in nature compared with 1966 the crystal
world
in his first truly mature work
Ballard draws from Joseph Conrad's Heart
of Darkness in his effort to symbolize
climate change as something far more
Insidious
transmutation of the atomic structure of
nature itself one that's gradually
rendering all flora and fauna as Crystal
it's a startling yet subtle work that
cuts to the heart of the Stark reality
of climate change that we might be soon
be living in a world that's
fundamentally alien to us
in a sense now I really love this
the crystal world
is a body horror novel
except that instead of the body horror
happening to a person it's happening to
the Earth
I think this is a very insightful set of
remarks here
uh another really interesting analysis
is provided by ardini in resurrected
from its own sewers waste landscape in
the environment in JG Ballard's climate
novel and the idea here is that waste
trash repurposing is at the center of
what's going on as a theme in JG
Ballard's works and so he talks about
the crystal World providing a fitting
end to the climate novels insofar as it
takes the question of what one does with
waste to its most extreme conclusion
where drowned world envisions a world of
nature machine hybrids composed of
manufactured effluvia overgrown by
plants and the drought explores ways of
transforming waste into object's Dart or
dwellings this last text imagines the
transformation of objects into artifacts
of themselves and humans into something
that is in one of the characters words
neither animate nor inanimate neither
alive nor dead
in this way the crystal World renders
the tension between past and future
humankind in nature wastage in making
new and self and Landscape
still more explicit
right and going on
it says it is this this uh
what's this crystallization a disaster
far more open to interpretation than the
flood and the drought of the previous
two texts
for the multiple jewel-like artifacts or
sculptures into each into which each
object is transformed are uh at the
novels outset prizes lucrative
Commodities by local market stall owners
and to be integrated into the local
economy put differently the text appears
to elliptically explore a more extreme
version of the catastrophe outline in
the drought for the crystallized
multiplying structures in the crystal
world are but a more intrusive visible
and ubiquitous version of the plastic
polymers
coating the sea in its predecessor
so this is a very interesting thing and
then finally
um
Moritz in ingervescence
environmental catastrophe has
morphogenesis inhuman transformations in
Ballard's climate novels has a couple
interesting things to say so this has to
do with
entropy
as several Scholars have noted the
overriding scientific framework
governing Ballard's early novels is the
second law of Thermodynamics first
formulated by Rudolph clausius in 1850
it axiomatizes that every
thermodynamically closed system will
succumb to the eventual disintegration
of order and structure as available
energy is dissipated the system's
entropy reaches a maximum a condition
that corresponds to a uniform
statistical distribution of particles
and velocities antithetically to the
Victorian fetishization of industrial
and social progress it seemed to sketch
an evolutionary path and an ineluctably
ends and demise the notorious heat death
of the universe not a fiery apocalypse
but the eventual transformation of all
kinetic and potential energy into random
quivering of Elementary particles
so-called thermal noise
now he goes on and writes via its
introduction of irreversible action the
second law of Thermodynamics provided an
implicit definition of a linear and
unidirectional flow of time the universe
was not only A mechanistic Clockwork But
A Clockwork running down so what we've
got here right Victorian progress things
are getting better and better ooh crap
the universe is breaking down and
there's nothing we can do about it
here's where we get a third possibility
this is very interesting
so
the author goes on to say
um
Ballard's literalizations of the second
law of Thermodynamics and its shorthand
reduction of the Specter of increasing
entropy
decisively depart from Victorian and
modernist imaginaries
admits dissipative dissipative
environmental conditions his
protagonists are Ambiguously caught in a
process not only of dissolution entropy
but of transformation
the material forces of in his
environments and disequilibrium
precipitate both ruination entropy and
rebirth
Lawrence Pershing is right to call
Ballard's apocalypse ambiguous but I am
less inclined to agree that this
vexation is merely a response to the
ambiguous nature of Modern Life I would
like to advance that his fiction
metabolizes the ambiguous nature of
material morphological changing in form
processes a concern that can be traced
along a shift
in 20th century science to the study of
open systems the self-organizing
capacities of inorganic matter and the
fuzzy dividing lines between life and
non-life right so this is saying that
Ballard drawing on the surrealists is
actually putting forth a vision in which
we have an estranged environment no
longer framed as the externalization of
a rationalistic human gaze or a world
for us and he says just as in the just
as the ego and the age of psychoanalysis
is no longer the master of its own house
Earth becomes an alien planet
so what we have here in these novels is
the transformation
of human beings to bring it all back
together
the element of Inner Space that's
Central to ballards uh conception of
where science fiction ought to be the
changing World which offers not just a
breakdown but the possibility for
transformation but transformation
meaning you can't go back to the order
that there was previously and this is
what we do see
in each of some each of the novels with
certain of the characters so I think
this might provide us with some useful
lenses for understanding what is
actually going on not just in Ballard's
works as a whole or as thought as a
whole but particularly in these three
great cli-fi environmental collapse
catastrophe novels
in addition to the transformations of
the environment and its things its flora
and fauna we can say that there's a lot
of changes in human beings and their
social structures their relationships
their understandings of themselves
happening in these works and
we can't really say just in addition
because these are intimately connected
what we have in the case of the drowned
world is a cataclysm that has been going
on now for really Generations but
interestingly there's still a lot of
structure not so much among the
characters themselves but
further north further south right and we
see a breakdown happening in the drought
or the burning world and then we have
even the most massive adjustment
occurring in the crystal world but only
towards the end and only hinted at so
what do we mean by this
well you know each of these novels does
have characters of the normal sense and
there's conflicts between them there's
cooperation between them there's
dialogues and interchanges and telling
people what matters to them and each of
them is marked by let's call them
several crazy characters strangmen in
The drowned World
um Venter in in the the crystal world
we could come up with a couple Lomax
quilty
um the the preacher in the drought and
some of them can be quite dangerous they
work at Cross purposes you know the main
character or let's say not the main
character but the central character
um in the the drowned World almost dies
Karen's because of what it is that is
imposed upon Him by this wild crazy guy
strangman
so there's all of that going on
we also do have
male female relationships you know some
of which are in the past some of which
are seemingly you know they're not
completely non-sexual but the characters
aren't actually having sex a lot of the
time and so you know there's all of
these things that make up human life
going on
but with each of the characters the main
characters because each one is centered
around a
key character whose middle aged
well-educated kind of detached from the
rest of the
activities and structures that are that
are going on not committing themselves
entirely until they do commit themselves
each of them is a let's say not just a
representation but an exploration of
what Ballard has called Inner Space and
let's remember too as we just reminded
ourselves Inner Space according to
Ballard is not a pure interiority or
like a interior monologue or the
insanity of somebody cut off from the
rest of the world
Inner Space
refers to how their own psychological
condition relates to the external World
which is in process of changing and in
some respects the characters are
undergoing similar things to what the
other characters are but there's also
the possibility
of transformation that Embraces
what is happening and the other really
key elements so we've talked about space
but time
also plays a central role in each of
these so let's look at the drowned world
first
we find out uh quite early on that
Karen's um
is kind of a different person we read it
was perhaps this absence of personal
memories that made Karen's indifferent
to the spectacle of these sinking
civilizations he'd been born and brought
up entirely within what had once been
known as the Arctic Circle now a
subtropical Zone with an annual mean
temperature of 85 degrees and it comes
Southward only on joining one of the
ecological surveys in his early 30s the
vast swamps and jungles had been a
fabulous laboratory the submerged cities
little more than elaborate pedestals so
he doesn't have that much of a stake in
the ruin of the Europe that that he is
inhabiting along with these other
characters now we get something really
interesting uh brought up fairly early
on and Bodkin and Karen's are talking
and Bodkin says
um I'm not suggesting that homo sapiens
is going to transform himself into you
know a lower form of human being
but after two or three hundred million
years Homo sapiens might well die out
and her little cousin the Marmot here
might become the highest form of life on
the planet however a biological process
isn't completely reversible
um and so he goes on and he says I'm
really thinking of something else
is it only the external landscape which
is altering how often recently most of
us have had the feeling of deja vu of
having seen this all before
in fact of remembering these swamps and
lagoons all too well however selective
the conscious mind may be most
biological memories are unpleasant ones
Echoes of danger and Terror nothing
endures for so long as fear everywhere
in nature one sees evidence of innate
releasing mechanisms literally millions
of years old which have laying dormant
through thousands of generations but
have retained their power undiminished
the field rats inherited image of the
hawk silhouette is a classic example
how else can you explain the universal
but completely groundless loathing of
the spider only one species of which has
ever been known to sting or equally
surprising in view of their comparative
Rarity hatred of snakes and reptiles
simply because we all carry within
ourselves a submerged memory of the time
when the giant spiders were lethal and
when the reptiles were the planet's
dominant life form
and so he said so Karen says you're
frightened The increased temperature and
radiation are alerting similar irms in
our own minds and the doctor goes on not
in our minds Robert these are the oldest
memories on Earth the time codes carried
in every chromosome and Gene every step
we've taken in our evolution is a
milestone inscribed with Organic
memories from the enzymes controlling
the carbon dioxide cycle to the
organization of the brachial plexus and
the nerve Pathways of pyramidal
pyramidal cells in the midbrain each is
a record of a thousand decisions taken
in the face of a sudden physical
Chemical Crisis just as psychoanalysis
reconstructs the original traumatic
situation in order to release the
repressed material we
are now being plunged back into the
archaeo physic past
under covering the ancient taboos and
drives that have been dormant for epics
the brief span of an individual life is
misleading every one of us is as old as
the entire biological Kingdom and our
bloodstreams are tributaries of the
great sea of its total memory the
uterine Odyssey of the growing fetus
recapitulates the entire evolutionary
past and its central nervous system is a
coded time scale each Nexus of neurons
in each spinal level marking a symbolic
station a unit of neuronic time the
further down the central nervous system
you move you descend back into the
neuronic past
so he calls this the psychology of total
equivalence or neuronics for short and
he says as we move back through geograph
geophysical time we re-enter the
amniotic Corridor and move back through
spinal and archaeo psychic time
recollecting in our unconscious minds
the Landscapes of each Epoch each with a
distinctive geological terrain its own
unique flora and fauna as recognizable
to anyone else as they would be to a
traveler in a wellesian time machine so
we've got this interesting Theory going
on being articulated by this this doctor
at this point
that as the
Earth is being reverted back to earlier
eras we ourselves are inevitably going
so now he adds one other thing
this is no Scenic Railway but a total
reorientation of the personality if we
let these buried Phantoms Master us as
they reappear will be swept back
helplessly in the flood time like pieces
of Flotsam right so that's an
interesting prospect that maybe they
could resist right resistance could mean
moving North to where it's cooler at
least for a Time
then a bit later on we find out about
something that they've been undergoing
so Beatrice doll doll has been having
these bad dreams right and Karen's knew
that for some reason he'd been reluctant
to give Beatrice any real sympathy
cutting his questions about the
nightmares as short as possible never
offering her treatment or sedative nor
had he tried to follow up any of Bodkins
or Riggs oblique remarks about the
dreams and their danger almost as if he
had known he would soon be sharing them
and accepted them as an inevitable
element of his life like the image of
his own death each carried with him in
the secret places of his heart
so Bodkin says to him so you're one of
the dreamers now Robert you beheld the
Fatima Morgana of the terminal Lagoon
you look tired right and so these These
Dreams
um
are being experienced by many of the
people there and Bodkin says you've held
out for a long time it's quite a tribute
to the strength of your pre-conscious
filters we were all wondering when you'd
arrive figuratively of course I've never
discussed the dreams with anyone except
for Hardman and their poor chap the
dreams were having him Hardman is going
to actually take off into the jungle and
we'll find him at the very end so
they're not only like you know beginning
to revert in certain ways their dream
life is doing that as well and we find
out that it's affecting people's
decision making too
so there is a seeming accident that
might actually be an attempt at suicide
and strangman says something very
interesting
um don't perpetuate a myth Karen's will
be much more grateful for the truth he
anchored that cable himself quite
deliberately why because he wanted to
become part of the drowned world and the
joke is he doesn't know whether I'm
telling the truth or not do you realize
that Bodkin look at him he genuinely
isn't sure
and then Beatrice says stop saying that
it might have been an accident and
strangman says it might let's admit that
did I or did I not try to kill myself
one of the few existential absolutes far
more significant than to be or not to be
which merely underlines the uncertainty
of suicide rather than the Eternal
ambivalence of his victim and he says
Karen Zay Envy the you the task of
finding out if you can so Karen's is
starting to
crack up to slide away into what we
might consider Madness but it might also
just be considered a transformation of
the Inner Space and we we come to the
end where Karen has gone off into the
jungle
and he finds uh in the very last chapter
Hardman whose eyes have long since been
burnt out uh who's quite sick and he
nurses him back to health
Ann Hardman uh takes off into the jungle
and then he decides he's going to go
south
Karen's is going deeper into the jungle
and he says he knew that Hardman would
sue die and his own life might not long
survive the mass of unbroken jungles to
the South so he writes 27th day have
rested and then moving south all is well
and so that's an interesting thing he's
not
morning he's not despairing he is off
entering into a new landscape and a new
era with a different personality
what happens in the next novel the
drought
again we find the same sorts of
strange transformations of Personality
taking place and I'm just going to bring
up a few with Ransom that are happening
very early on in the in the very first
chapter at the end of it we read
throughout the long summer Ransom had
watched the river shrinking its
countless associations
fading as it narrowed into a shallow
Creek above all Ransom was aware of the
role of the river in time that the role
of the river in time had changed once it
had played the part of an immense fluid
clock the objects immersed in it taking
up their positions like the Stations of
the Sun and planets the continued
lateral movements of the river its rise
and fall and the varying pressures on
the hull were like the activity within a
vast system of evolution whose
cumulative forward flow was an
irrelevant and without meaning as the
Apparently linear motion of time itself
the real move movements were those
random and discontinuous relationships
between the objects within it those of
himself and Mrs quilter her son and the
dead birds and fish with the death of
the river so Advantage any contact
between those stranded on the drained
floor for the present the need to find
some other measure of their
relationships would be concealed by the
problems of their own physical Survivor
survival
nonetheless Ransom was certain that the
absence of this great moderator the
river which cast its bridges between all
animate and inanimate objects would
prove of crucial importance each of them
would soon literally be an island in an
archipelago
drained of time
Now isn't that an interesting idea
time
isn't stopping of course it goes on but
the meaning of time is changing as the
landscape is becoming desiccated and the
flow of water is ending
a little bit later on we read that
Ransom is talking to to Whitman about
these different people that are that are
you know prowling around and he said um
he realized he's talking about
Lomax and Miranda he realized the role
of the recluse and solitary meditating
on his past sins of a mission like a
Hermit on the fringes of an abandoned
city would not be viable the blighted
landscape and its empty violence its
loss of time would provide its own
motives these latent elements in Lomax
and Miranda to people that he knows that
are rich and crazy were already
appearing
um
and he goes on and he says perhaps this
Phantom The Phantom of Miranda embodied
archaic memories of a Time whether past
or future when fear and pain were the
most valuable emotions and their
exploitation into the most perverse
forms the sole imperative
now we're getting something that kind of
Harkens back to what was being
referenced in the drown world except
here
notice this their exploitation into the
most perverse forms of fear and pain and
that is what does in fact happen by the
end of the book with Lomax with Miranda
with quilter with all these characters
and he goes on and he there's a
narration
it was this sense of remorseless Caprice
with its world of infinite possibilities
unrestrained by any moral considerations
which had it as its expression in the
figure of the white-haired Witch
so that's quite an interesting thing to
note and then much later on in it we
find that this is five years well Ten
Years Later actually but for five years
Ransom has been living with Judith and
um she's not making a lot of
contributions but he's he uh we read it
was not this the fact that she would
guard their water and fish stocks that
held them together but their awareness
that only with each other could they
keep alive some faint shadow of their
former personalities whatever their
defects and arrest the gradual numbing
of sense and identity that was an
unseeden gradient of the Dune limbo like
all purgatories the beach was a waiting
ground the endless stretches of wet salt
sucking away from them all but the
hardest core of themselves these tiny
nodes of identity glimmered in the light
of the limbo the zone of nothingness
that waited for them to dissolve and
deliquis like the crystals dried by the
Sun
so
isn't that an interesting set of
observations about the toll that this is
taking on all these different people
then with the crystal world we really
don't get to see the effects on
persons and their psyches apart from
their bodies until about halfway through
the book
and
um
there's a very interesting set of
Reflections about time and about the
forest where the crystallization is
taking place
so uh Sanders says you've been here
before and ventresses do you mean Deja
Vu and Sandra says I mean literally and
Ventress then says we've all been here
before doctors everyone will soon find
out if there's time he pronounced the
world with a peculiar inflection of his
own drawing it out like the tolling of a
bell he listened to the last Echoes
reverberate away among the crystal walls
like a fading Requiem however I feel
that's something we're all running out
of doctor do you agree
so this is going to be a key theme of
the
the catastrophe that the crystallization
is it's affecting time itself
so
the the doctor says running out of time
I haven't thought about it yet what's
your explanation
isn't it obvious doctor doesn't your own
specialty the dark side of the sun we
see around us here provide a clue surely
leprosy like cancer is above all a
disease of time a result of over
extending oneself through that
particular medium
and then Sandra says well it's a theory
and then Ventress says look at the
viruses doctor with their crystalline
structure neither animate nor inanimate
and their immunity to time
you and I will be like them soon Sanders
and the rest of the world neither living
nor dead
Now isn't that kind of a frightening
Prospect to contemplate a little bit
later on in here we find out that
Sanders made what he calls an appalling
blunder he finds this man radic
completely crystallized and he tries to
immerse him in the river and he had to
tear him loose some of the crystals came
off the crystals were the man
and so
um
parts of him are gone but now here's the
most interesting part he says
Max I don't understand me it wasn't just
that the point is he wanted to go back
he wanted to go back in the forest and
be crystallized again he knew Max he
knew
so radic a doctor himself had wanted to
go back into the crystalline state that
he'd been transformed into and this is
what's going to happen to quite a few
people
later on we find that the area in the
forest is spreading about a hundred feet
a day and half this is happening in
other places including Florida half the
state has been evacuated and Suzanne
says can you imagine that Edward an
entire city all those hundreds of white
hotels transformed into stained glass
and uh Max says you make it sound like
the New Jerusalem before you could turn
around I'm afraid you'd find yourself an
angel in a rose window and so they're
able to understand what is happening to
the world and the people within it
um now there's a character a priest
baltus who plays a somewhat significant
role in this and he says some quite
interesting things as well so balthus
says
um it may be it may sound heretical to
say so but the body of Christ is with us
everywhere here in every prism and
Rainbow in the ten thousand faces of the
Sun so you see I fear that the church
like its symbol may have outlived its
function
and Balta says once I was a true
opposite I knew God existed but I could
not believe in him now events have
overtaken me
for a priest there is no greater crisis
to deny God when he can be seen to exist
in every leaf and flower and at the very
end of baltus's discourse he'll say
in this Forest where all of the
crystallization is taking place we see
the final celebration of the Eucharist
the transformation right of Christ's
body here everything is transfigured and
illuminated joined together now notice
these words in the last marriage of
space and time
not only is the landscape being
transformed but time is also being
transformed and the last uh passage that
I want to
bring up here is towards the the
end of the book and you know they're
saying there's not much point to doctors
right now
um you know we're not going to actually
cure people of of all of this sort of
stuff and what we find out is that Max
who's married to Suzanne
doesn't quite understand
the significance of the forest for
Suzanne and Sanders what is the
significance here we get back to the
Inner Space theme that for both of them
the only final resolution of the
imbalance within their minds
their inclination toward the dark side
of the Equinox could be found in that
Crystal world
so in each of these we actually have
mentions of the the title right and the
mention of the drowned world the crystal
World these are places that human beings
despite the the strange Transformations
that are required can participate in can
evolve or devolve or transform to be
members of and in some respect
understand themselves differently and
approach the world differently so on
that philosophical theme so
interestingly laid out in these three
novels we end our discussion of these
environmental catastrophe novels of
Ballard and we bring this to a close
[Music]
thank you